Charlie says, should I increase my targeting radius if I'm not getting enough impressions?
My client said he can travel up to 60 mile radius. I would, but I wouldn't do 60 miles.
I might do like 30 because they say that. But then guess what? As soon as the leads start freaking
coming in, they're going to want to stay close to home. So yeah, I don't think there's anything
wrong with bumping it out. But before you do that, Charlie, I would go and make sure,
is the CPC under five bucks? Is the due diligence correct? Are you in the niches that I'm talking
about? Are you in the cities that I'm trying to show you how to get into? Do you have the ad set
up exactly? Are you running a smart campaign? Are you doing exactly as I trained before you go in
and expand it? That's the only thing that I would say before you do it. But yeah, I don't see
anything. That's a very minor thing. Maybe I start with, you know, from 15 to 20, then to 25 and to
30, but don't go to 60. I'm just telling you from experience, you're going to go to 60, you're going
to get more leads. And then he's going to go, ah, I'm getting, I just got this referral and like
now I'm busy. I don't need it. And you're like, bro, I just spent all this money on ads, dude.